Friends was just a hand-clappy
theme song and six random
hot people fucking eachother.
Well thats not true. Five random
hot people and David Scwimmer's
droppy dog sadness that
disguises itself as actual
stage presence.
And it inspired a whole
generation of bland hot people
fucking sitcoms.
None of which had a fun
hand-clappy theme song
which is why Friends is
considered a classic.
But it's not a classic. Sienfeld
is a classic, The Simpsons is a
classic
Friends is remembered more for
its haircuts than its
punchlines.
and is as memorable as a Tinder
date where you didn't even get
to make out and had to pay for
your half of the meal.
Beards are disgusting snack food
traps.
Mmm. Honey Mustard Pringles.
And any man that has one is just
too insecure to show you his
real face.
I'm not a real man, but Lord
knows my face is doing
a decent impression of one.
My face says "I'll start a bar
fight to defend a womans honor"
but the rest of me says
"confrentation makes me feel
very naseous"
The unrealistic expectations
your parents put on you
and your inability to fullfil
them is what ruined your
childhood
Why can't you play sports?
Why'd you get a 1060 on your
SATs?
We paid for a tutor!
George Lucus gave you a happy go
lucky minstral gungan called
Darth Vador Ani. That's it. And
you know what he did with the
money he made
selling Star Wars to Disney? He
gave all 4.6 billion of it to
inner city school programs so
he's actively enriching
childhoods.
What have you done besides
complain about George Lucus?
Yea. Mesa-thought-so.